guess where all the rich people are
moving where all the freaking rich
people are moving guess how much jeff
bezos currently the second richest man
in the world just bought a house what
state
um
florida hawaii
jeff bezos just bought a 78 million
dollar compound in
hawaii
okay
78 million how do you 78 million dollar
house what does that even mean okay
uh miami star island l.a yeah you know
calabasas the hollywood hills you know
but the real savages i feel like are
going to hawaii right marcelo thank you
for that intro so he just added another
property to his amazon cart so to speak
so his lady friended him
lauren
sanchez they bought a 14-acre maui
estate maui hawaii it includes a 4 500
square foot main house a 1700 square
foot guest house because you've got to
have a guest house obviously
and a massive ass 700 square foot
swimming pool which includes a fish pond
and a private
beach
um
well played mr bezos something tells me
that you're gonna be able to afford your
mortgage for this one golf clap goes to
you but other high-profile people are
also moving to hawaii who has moved
there none other than our friend
shaquille o'neal
shaq is not hawaii he's got to do his
stuff on tnt zuk has a place there
mark zuckerberg a few places there right
he recently i guess expanded what he
currently owns so a total of 1300 acres
in kauai
and then oracle larry ellison one of the
more eccentric big tech billionaires he
owns his own island there
on the island of lanai
he owns most of the aisles most of the
other i apologize there's some part of
the island for his staff
and then
queen oprah also owns a major property
in hawaii so look these are next
level wealthy people buying property in
hawaii okay so here's the here's the
game that i want to play before we wrap
up
david you're now worth a billion dollars
because we said after 100 episodes
you're now worth a billion dollars yeah
yeah you can go move anywhere you want
live anywhere you want boca where you
living
to boca raton florida anywhere i want i
don't know somewhere i could go and
watch all the chelsea games whenever i
want some in the heart of west london so
you're moving to london west your life
is based around your chelsea
football
perfect world yeah i live in west london
a beautiful apartment i go and i watch
chelsea every day and i follow them
across europe fair enough marcelo
hold on before marcelo guys you're worth
a billion dollars you're zuck you're
larry ellison you're freaking bezos
you're oprah you've got hundreds 100
million dollars
you can live anywhere you want put it in
the comments
where would you live
marcelo marcelo it is now on you people
are making comments in the comment
section um if i could live anywhere in
the world
um
i don't know dude
i don't know dude like right now like
i'm 24 years old yeah i get the billy
and now i can be anywhere
i don't know i'd probably live in like a
penthouse in like new york or something
i like that that would be a good second
house i'd probably live in a pedestal i
know my answer i know my answer
i'm going to do a half and half approach
six months out of the year straight up
living in south beach florida buddy the
best place to be in the world in the
winter time right now is winter time six
months out of the year in the summer
time you will not catch me
in miami you will not catch me in
florida you'll not catch me in the south
i'm traveling i'm going to new york i'm
going to europe
i'm
taking off baby i'm taking off three
months
three months three months three months
with you in london three months ago
this guy said where would you live he
didn't say could you break down your
life foreign
this guy's like i think i might also put
some money in bitcoin it's like no
brother where would you live you got a
billy i just said south beach but i'm
not gonna live there all year long
whatever dude do you think these guys
are living in ohio wake up pick a place
just those guys in the heart of west
london beautiful
penthouse in new york you're the only
one that gets to travel don't be mad
that you didn't think about traveling
don't be mad
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay
[Music]
we talk is broken